hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the vital distinctions that
Audrey Lord makes in her short address
the uses of anger is that between the
emotion of anger in its expression and
its origins in its objects and a
different emotion which she calls hatred
and which we should understand in a
broad sense now what she's saying here
is actually something that's not
particularly new but it's being applied
in a context that could be novel for
many people and I think quite rightly so
in its application it's something that
goes back all the way for example to
Aristotle and his discussions of these
two emotions of anger and hatred but
Lord is bringing to it a not just focus
on individual people's emotions but on
social and political and we could it's a
cultural structures as well so what is
she saying she tells us that anger is a
not just a response to racism but a
legitimate response to racism and what
we see here is it can be a response not
just to racism but to sexism or to
classism or other types of Injustice and
discrimination many of which she touches
upon within this work where the central
focus is indeed racism and she'll talk
about two different dimensions without
going into any you know great
theoretical depth about the
interconnections between these because
she assumes that I think the audience is
rather familiar with it so we can talk
about people having beliefs you know
racism itself she tells us is the belief
in the inherent superiority of One race
over all others and it's expressed in
attitudes in actions in this very
interesting term presumptions which I
think is great for capturing an entire
range of things from assumptions all the
way to decisions that people make oh no
you wouldn't be interested in that
because you aren't you know from this
group or class or something like that
and those can be understood as you know
group oriented but on the part of
individuals but then there is an entire
political and social Dimension as she
tells us as well which includes
oppression and exploitation she uses the
word domination as well and these tend
to precede us historically right we're
born into these structures sometimes
they change over time and we get new uh
iterations on it and she uses three
terms that I think are very apt here
that kind of intersect with each other
she talks about a system
right living within a racist system an
exploitative system uh context that's
another good way of thinking about it
and then she talks about individual or
institutional right so our institutions
themselves can be places and spaces
where these Dynamics play themselves out
even if people are you know not
harboring racism in their heart or
saying racist things sometimes the way
things are set up can
um
lead to we could call it racist outcomes
and there's a interplay between the two
of these the individual and Society
right and she you know she she says that
the responses to the legitimate anger
that those who experience racism and are
affected by it actually feel and then
Express the responses that many people
have to this
reflect a distorted perspective and what
is the key to that perspective
identifying women of colors anger as the
fundamental problem rather than seeing
the anger itself as a response to what
the real problem is that's scarier that
needs to be addressed that's harder to
call out because it's usually something
involving those who have power Prestige
Wealth all these things that Elevate
them above those who are marginalized
and vulnerable and she talks she's
talking to her fellow feminists in this
case and saying a lot of you are racists
a lot of you are treating women of
colors anger as if it's the real problem
when it's not and you could actually be
learning from it it's uncomfortable but
instead you're talking about your fears
your guilt that you feel don't get angry
at me because then I feel guilty rather
than oh you're angry I better figure out
how to deal with my my own guilt anger
that is a counter response to the
expression of anger who are you to
complain about this you're lucky that we
even gave you a seat at the table uh
accusations of the anger being useless
or disruptive this reflects Lord is
saying here a fundamentally
mistaken though understandable but not
excusable
attitude perspective however you want to
express it and she does say listen uh
women often have a lack of tools for
facing each other's anger constructively
and we need to work on that this could
be extended not just to women dividing
things up in terms of race but as she
points out in terms of class in terms of
age we could think about ability we
could think of all sorts of other things
as well and then she's got this very
interesting passage as where she talks
about women who have been or and really
anybody who has been raised to fear and
um
the the problem
um with that right so those who have
been raised to fear anger now whose
anger is she is she talking about well
it could be fear of the anger of those
who are powerful it could be anger of
their own that they don't want to admit
feel Express act upon because then that
could lead to problems or it could be
the anger of women of color who are
raising issues of racism and bringing up
all sorts of
issues as well right so
this covers a lot of ground and what is
the fear so she says for women Raised To
Fear
too often anger threatens Annihilation
Annihilation is being reduced to nothing
could be being killed it could be being
raped it could be having your livelihood
uh deprived right it could be having
your children taken away it could be
being ostracized
so women have in many cases learn to
fear the anger she says in the male
construct of Brute Force we were taught
our lives depended on The Good Will of
patriarchal power the anger of others
was to be avoided at all costs why
because there was nothing to be learned
from it but pain a judgment we'd been
bad girls come up lacking not done what
we were supposed to do and if we accept
our powerlessness then of course any
anger can destroy us the anger that that
oneself feels the anger that others who
are marginalized feel the anger of those
who are powerful even if they're only
powerful within certain contexts and so
you know she she says it's
understandable that people would have
um wrong-headed perspectives about anger
but now let's actually produce a proper
perspective and she spends a lot of the
space in this address actually doing
this that is
clarifying what it is that the real evil
the real threat is and she's going to
use this distinction between anger and
hatred to articulate this so she early
on talks about a system I mentioned this
she says we're not here as women
examining racism in a political and
social vacuum
we operate in the teeth of a system for
which racism and sexism are primary
established and necessary props for
profit and you could say oh she's
attacking capitalism yeah that's
probably true she's attacking an
unrestricted or crony capitalism or
capitalism that uses racism and sexism
as structures and devices to extract
everything that it can out of people it
could be other systems that are doing
that as well though the key here is that
these forms of discrimination and
Injustice are and notice these three
qualifiers
primary so this is something that is
there to be seen
established these have been around for a
long time maybe you know since the start
and necessary if the system is going to
go on as it is it is necessary that
people be discriminated against
exploited dominated mistreated in uh not
just individual ways but in systematic
ways
and then for profit for somebody's
profit somebody is getting something out
of this it could be money it could be a
sense of identity and self and
importance you know so long as somebody
can look down on those who are lesser
than them they actually feel like they
matter right and so she's uh she's
condemning that and then she talks about
a context
of opposition and threat she says we're
working in this context and then she
says what's the cause of this is the
cause of this the anger and now notice
that we have a much broader social
Dynamic here that's being criticized
when some people are being mistreated
and then they protest against that
mistreatment there's always a lot of
people coming along and saying why are
you being so angry why do you have to
engage in this protest now you're being
disruptive you're not going to
accomplish anything you're making us
feel bad you know and Audrey Lord is
saying
hey anger didn't cause this anger didn't
create this anger is a response to this
she says the cause of this context of
opposition and threat is not the angers
which lie between us when we criticize
each other and respond authentically to
each other what is the cause
the cause is she says that virulent
hatred leveled against all women people
of color lesbians and gay men poor
people against what do they all have in
common she's going to specify this
against all of us who are seeking to
examine the particulars of Our Lives as
we resist our oppressions moving towards
Coalition and effective action now
there's two things going on there
there's there's a hatred of the other of
the one who is made lesser by the
culture by individual choices by those
who benefit from it right sometimes
internalized by those very same people
so long as they can criticize or direct
that hatred against somebody lower than
themselves right and that's what she's
accusing white women in the feminist
movement of doing
but it becomes especially virulent
hatred when those people are like hey
we've had enough of this crap we're
going to organize we're going to
criticize we're going to try to change
things we're going to stand up against
that then the hatred
re-intensifies right so this context of
opposition
and she says you know a couple things
it's not our anger which makes me
caution you to lock your doors at night
and not to wander the streets of
Hartford alone it is the hatred that
lurks in those streets and what is that
hatred the urge to destroy us all if we
truly work for change rather than merely
indulge in academic rhetoric and then
she says this hatred and our anger are
very different
hatred she says is the fury of those who
do not share our goals and its object is
what death and destruction
destroying reducing annihilating taking
other people and turning them into
objects and then destroying those
objects if they get out of line
she tells us anger is a grief of
distortions between peers its object is
change
but our time is getting shorter we've
been raised to view any difference other
than sex as a reason for Destruction and
black women and white women have to face
each other's anger right
she goes on a little bit further later
on and tells us that uh
here we go it is at the very end
it is not the anger of black women which
is dripping over this globe like a
disease liquid it is not my anger that
launches Rockets spends over sixty
thousand dollars a second on missiles
and other agents of war and death
Slaughters children in cities stockpiles
nerve gas and chemical bombs sodomizes
our daughters and our Earth it is not
the anger of black women which corrodes
into blind dehumanizing power bent upon
the annihilation of us all unless we
meet it with what we have and so you
know she's recognizing there is a
genuine hatred flowing out there
embodied in some of our very social
structures which are not just hatred but
which Encompass that and we shouldn't
mix that up with the anger that people
are legitimately feeling the last thing
that I want to bring up is a really key
point that that she's making and it's
encompassed in one sentence
if I speak to you in Anger at least I
have spoken to you
being angry with another person does not
mean being bent upon their destruction
that is hatred
being angry with another person involves
recognition of the other as a screwed up
person is the one who did the angering
thing who may be you know exhibiting
racist attitudes but who is still a
person who is still treated as a human
being she says I have not put a gun to
your head and shot you down in the
street I've not looked at your bleeding
sister's body and asked what did she do
to deserve it that is what hatred does
hatred blames the victim hatred attacks
those who rise up against oppression or
those who are in solidarity with them
perhaps viewed as you know traitors
against their own class or race or sex
or pick whatever other differential you
want and so Lord is telling her fellow
white feminists she's a black lesbian
feminist in this case that they're
really getting anger wrong when viewing
people of colors anger as something
that's the real problem instead of
looking where the real problem is and
identifying that and working against it
and she's saying you can handle anger as
a matter of fact it's very important
that we learn how to be angry with each
other and maintain a proper perspective
so this distinction between anger and
hatred can be an essential part of that